Next, a real life love story
that shows timing is everything.
"People" reports, a couple named Paul Mattingly
and Laura Lee Estees got married
for the second time over the pandemic
after living apart for 40 years.
Oh, look at 'em.
Their first wedding
was in 1980, fresh outta college.
They were too young to make it work.
And then, they divorced and they drifted apart.
But then in 2019, Laura Lee was passing through Paul's town
and reached out.
"And did he wanna go to dinner?", she asked.
They were both single.
Paul says the moment he saw her,
it was love at second sight.
Oh.
Laura Lee said, "It was like seeing the best friend
"you haven't seen in years."
And they just celebrated their one year anniversary
in their 60's.
And now, their mantra is they just wanna make up
for lost time.
I love this.
This is so cute.
That goes into timing is everything too.
Absolutely, and what I call this,
I've said here before,
I love when people hook up again.
I call it reheating your leftovers
when it's been in the fridge for a while.
You liked it once, maybe I just nuke it a little bit,
I'll want it again.
40 years, I hope it was in the freezer
and not the fridge.
Yeah, in a nice Tupperware.
Yeah, a little like Walt Disney cryo Stitch.
Are there any leftovers in your fridge
that you just can't stop thinking about,
maybe one day you're just gonna heat 'em up?
Are we talking about boys or soups?
I was not talking about soup.
Yes, I have revisited a few exes
and I keep coming up with the same thing,
which is a lot of good self discovery
that I've really grown up a lot
and I've made a lot of concerted effort
to kind of change my patterns and behaviors,
so it's kind of like all good news.
It is good news.
And I do believe timing is everything.
You could meet the right person at the wrong time.
And clearly they didn't.
How beautiful they reconnected 40 years later
for their love story.
I think it's very helpful.
I love it too.
I love it.
Yeah, none of my exes are interested
and there's nothing there.
They're all bird carcasses.
Oh my God!
(all laugh)
I'm telling you, all the relationships
in my past are like, there's nothing left,
there's nothing to revisit.
You've picked all of the meat off.
It's like vultures flying over and they're like,
"Nothing to eat here, move it along, boys!"
(upbeat music)